منذ ما يقرب من شهر، أصبحت غزة
معزولة بالكامل تقريبًا، والآن أخيرًا يخرج البعض
حاملين صورًا مثل تلك التي تم التقاطها على
هواتفهم مع قصصهم.
لا أعتقد أن هناك كلمات كافية في
القاموس الإنجليزي
لوصف معنى كل جين.  من خلال
صور أمل وياكو أثناء
مرورهما عبر رافا يوم الأربعاء،
تتحدث عن ارتياحهما باعتباره إيطاليًا،
وكان محظوظًا لأنه كان من أوائل الذين خرجوا حيث
سُمح لزوجته أمل بالمرور
معه على الرغم من أنها فلسطينية لمدة
يومين  لقد فقدنا الوعي تمامًا،
يمكنك فقط التفكير في
الأسوأ وتستمر في القول بأننا
سنكون التاليين، وهذا ما تستمر في
إخبار
نفسك به أننا سنكون التاليين، فالوضع
الإنساني
كارثي، ولا يمكننا العثور على الماء والطعام
والخبز  عندما يذهب الناس إلى المخابز
يموتون بشدة لأنهم قصفوا
جميع المخابز تقريبًا في غزة، ما
الفرق الذي ستحدثه الهدنة الإنسانية
لأنه ليس من المهم الوصول إلى
حقيقة إنسانية ولكن في حريق CE الفعلي، حريق
طويل الأمد بشروط قوية
يقول آزان إنهم  يعطوننا بعض
مسكنات الألم وبعد ذلك سيستمرون في
القضاء علينا ولكن على الأقل
سيكون لديك القدرة على الحصول على الماء،
لا أعرف ما إذا كانوا سيسمحون بالوقود
لأنه الآن أصبح الأمر محظورًا بالطبع
لكننا سنتدبر الأمر  للحصول على بعض
الماء وأه بعض الطعام وبعد ذلك يمكنهم
قتلنا ولكن مع عدم وجود أمل في الأفق،
اتخذت أمل وياكو أصعب
الخيارات تاركين وراءهما
غزة المحاصرة والمقصفة بالكامل، دورنا هو
أن نقول مثل اه مع
السكان  مثل الأشخاص المحتاجين،
الكثير من الناس يتحدثون عن هذا أه
هذا الخروج بمثابة انتصار لنا لكنه
ليس انتصارًا كما نحن، إنها
خسارة للجميع لأكون
صادقًا منذ الأمس كنت بالفعل
نادمًا على الخروج لأنني  طوال
اليوم لم أتمكن من الوصول إلى
عائلتي، لذلك لم أتمكن حتى من إخبارهم أنني
تمكنت من الوصول بأمان وأنني بخير وأعلم
أن والدتي توسلت إليّ بالفعل
للخروج من أجلي، ولم أكن لأفعل ذلك.  لقد فعلت ذلك وما
زلت أشعر أنه لم يكن ينبغي
لي أن أخرج، كما تعلمون ذنب البقاء الذي يقولون إن
المستقبل مستحيل تخيله حتى
عندما يتوجهون إلى إيطاليا ورؤوسهم
مليئة بغزة وقلوبهم يائسة
للعودة